anyway let's move on
let's play another
random
oh obese race played eight times before
i feel like i've played obese threes
like giving some kind of odds
okay e5 i'm going to play king's gambit
i still want to get a quaid variation
which wait how does the quake variation
go again
c3
oh d5 this is what i like to play
isn't there some line like d4
i think a mon hamilton played this
against me once
pretty sure this has a name too
it might be called the amman hamilton
ah now it's funny looking okay
hey i'm the first to win connect four
oh the black counter wins connect four
oh and now we're just fooling around
i won connect five
it was too much fun
i wonder at what point will black start
punishing me
for being so childish
don't do this don't do this
i'm in trouble now
i thought black was gonna keep this some
symmetry of the universe
i'm actually in some trouble i have two
legal moves
probably king d2
delayed
long cloud type thing
i feel so sad maybe i should have played
h4
i should play h4
i forgot my theory
i wonder if this like this position has
been reached before queenish war might
be a novelty
oh no
the queen is all up in my crib
at least i can play this move defending
a
a i can win connect eight
okay i feel happy again
what is this
position
this is like one of those positions
when we hear the the statement that
there's more like possible chess games
and atoms in the universe
this is one of those like possible
positions that just never happened this
position is bananas
um bananas
yeah this position is probably like very
high in fiber
i have to find some monkeys to feed it
too
i don't know what to do now
actually i know what to do
i want to trap the queen
wait f3 is not defended though
ah because my knight's on e2 blocking
the
thing i thought it was being so clever
too
oh maybe my plan is to do this and then
this
now this is kind of hard to assess
oh no wait i'm in trouble actually
i still have to carry through with my
plan
oh no
for those just joining this is
this is still real chess it's just kind
of confusing
confusing bananas
yeah i have to get banana republic to
sponsor this game
how does the escape happen
oh yeah the queen is in in prison
you have to watch the show
prison break
which i actually haven't watched
but i don't know if the queen is gonna
escape
it was pretty like hefty security
the queen might have to dig a hole
somewhere
why is rook 82 such a annoying threat
rook a2 is a monster thread actually
or is it
yeah
okay 2 king d3
then f takes e4 checkmate
would be slightly devastating
i'm calculating a really funny line
takes recur
here takes takes knight f6 king digs e5
makes c6 king takes f6
don't think i'm getting mated there
but it looks really terrifying
i might have to take one of the pawns
the other option is to take the rook and
then rook h2
but that just looks bad
wait a minute what was i
oh no this doesn't work if i take check
here it's still meat
maybe bishop b2
have to develop
before i can trap the queen
and now the idea is of rook a2 i have
king c1
it's still very unsettling
this is a key game too i've never lost
to obesity
trying to make it 9-0
it was 93 yeah 93 the problem is black
can take and then probably make another
queen
there's so many bad things to worry
about
like my king safety the fact that all of
my pawns are hanging
my pieces feel claustrophobic
yes
this game is a textbook example of
following the normal rules
development
yeah fiance
still theory
kind of not really but maybe
and this is what happens when you
exhaust like all other opening theory
you have to
find unexplored paths
it's kind of like discovering new
new land or new areas that have never
been touched before
like this game is is maybe like going to
the very bottom of the ocean
finding some obscure sea animals
see animals see creatures
so despite all the things i have to
worry about and black still has to worry
about the queen being trapped
i don't think there's an escape
just kind of funny
hi eric
long time no watch frown
oh i hope this game makes up for all the
time you haven't been watching
oh no c3 is coming
black has a pawn cube too
[Music]
and it looks so indestructible
but i think i'll just play this
and
a baby at last be happy
hey happy baby
tw
okay so i'm not too concerned about that
unless i
am i don't think i am
because i can take
yeah the queen's still trapped i mean
black can check me
it takes with check i take with knight
if rookie 2 i play king c1
eventually the checks will run out
[Music]
we're about to find out
i'm just making sure i'm not like
missing any mating ideas
my king has no moves currently
the plaque also now has no queen
currently
oh that's a pawn chain
at least black no longer has a pawn cube
or a queen
but these pawns terrify me
black has all the other pieces still too
i've only taken the queen of the pawn
okay i might as well sack a knight
yeah
and now
wait what
oh my rook was hanging
i didn't see that
next i'm winning some pawns
let's win some more pawns
this move is almost checkmate
but i would have knight a3
uh i could take a free rook
or
[Music]
i can keep attacking stuff
yeah it doesn't scare me too much
really doesn't scare me
okay now it feels like halloween again
so much free candy
probably gonna have a lot of cavities
soon
[Music]
let's take
take a night
uh where's my mates
there is my mates
okay
oh
i'm scared to see the computer graph of
this game
in average sent upon loss let's see it's
probably like 150 for each of us
which would basically translate to every
move we blundered the equivalent of like
a pawn or two
which was basically the case
hey
yeah i made eight blunders this game
but opponent made nine lenders
okay uh things for the game obese race
oh my gosh look at how many blunders
there were
like every pawn move in the opening
so has this been this position
so this this is
a thing that's happened on the chess
the most common move c5
it's so funny how
yeah there's still a significant number
of games from this
g4 most played
oh i was right so queen h4 was a novelty
queen h4 has never been played before
even though it's the best move probably
right
yeah by far the best move
most common move g5 but
yeah obese wanted to punish me
that's such a funny novelty
it's the first game ever that's had this
position
okay hi to youtube
i hope i'm not uploading too many like
mean games to youtube i hope youtube
people still find
pleasure in these types of games
also twitch chat says hi